joking you do I get to talk to you yeah
I cannot wait to see this I'm so excited
what have you actually seen so far the
movie I've seen I've seen some stuff
I've seen some stuff here and there
enough to be super excited about it I
mean you know we're still cutting it all
together and you know sweeten it all up
and all the visual effects and all that
jazz but it's there man I mean it's a
really good movie with a lot of heart
and a lot of humor and I mean it
basically everything I thought it was
gonna be you know when I read the script
and I was like yeah I think this is the
movie in my head and everything I've
seen is exactly that the trailer the
trailer was a perfect little slice of
exactly what I thought we were making
you know totally you know comedic Lee
even like you know the cool bits of
action and and I then they'll be more
dropped you know the beginning of the
year there's gonna be another trailer
that's at some point in the new year and
I can't wait for that to reach the
masses I mean do it sister I mean the
whole thing is a dream it's so dreamy
it's so dreamy no I know we we spoke
before you went to film and the thing is
and with the thing we both talked about
is that it I mean you won the like what
how can I explain this being an actor to
get apart he's winning the lottery but
to get apart like this he's like it's
like the Mega Millions yeah it's like
striking them with all the numbers yeah
it's you know I mean particularly become
from you know building my career really
on Chuck and being this kind of you know
down-on-his-luck nerdy guy working in a
big-box store and then 12 Comic Cons
later I'm showing up in a mall age with
a cape on and it's like this is so crazy
in Surrey yeah do you now have a
newfound respect for the rock and how he
is able to work out while filming a
movie bro
I I still don't know I mean it it takes
a village just say that and he's got an
incredible village around him to be able
to stay on that schedule because I even
with everything I'm doing I'm still not
able to reach the the rock level but
maybe one thing I I'm I hope that I'm
hope I hope I'm able to continue in this
journey that I'm on right now of
strength and wellness and health and the
happiness that it's brought from that
and like just transforming my body and
being stronger than I've ever been I
mean it's it's a really really cool I
always dreamed that I would get paid to
get into the best shape of my life and
that's essentially happening so I'm
having them there's a lot of talk to
down the road you and Dwayne Johnson
would fight as a black Adam are you
already excited for that oh hell yeah
what are you giving me who doesn't want
to beat the crap out of the rock come on
right I'm just trying to already picture
that I think it's
to be great uh the thing I'm really
excited about this Shazam movie is that
it is an origin story for your character
and it is not trying to involve the
bigger DC Universe it's just you and
it's your story yeah if you could
hypothetically have put like another DC
character it's like an easter egg just
walking by in the background is there
one that you would have liked to have
seen ah I mean all of them I don't know
that's a really difficult to Jews I
don't know I mean I think I think the
flash would be really well I always just
think like Shazam in a flash like if I
get a week if we if they make more
Justice League movies and I'm blessed
enough to be in those like I just keep
picturing that Shazam and the flash
would be chumming around a lot because
we're like the youngins of the group
kind of and little immature and whatever
and also both super fast so we it's like
what you saw the end of Justice League
to Superman in the flash having their
foot race like we'd be doing that all
the time like just constantly racing
each other to see who's fastest and also
it just be funny I mean maybe if for all
we know maybe the flash doesn't make
walkthrough cameo he didn't even think
about that
yeah my last thing for you what did you
take away from this experience of what
did you learn making the movie that if
you're fortunate enough to be able to
make a sequel or play the character
again you want to bring with you I would
want to make I wouldn't want to make
some adjustments on the suit just to
make it a little more comfortable
sometimes cuz it's super tight and you
know there's a lot of like pieces and
it's really amazing I mean the suits
amazing it looks beautiful and it lights
up and everything but it I was freezing
like we shot it in Toronto in the middle
of winter and it didn't keep me warm at
all and then we'd go into stage and you
know be in a you know inside and I would
be burning up so we kind of find and we
gotta find out what alert the porch of
the designers and find a happy medium
that that I'm not roasting in or
freezing in I think I'd be great on that
note I gotta go
pleasure to see you again sir you too
you